there is really only one a true winner
and her name rhymes with gnarly today
she was nothing if not on message
joining us now from Simi Valley
California Carly Fiorina Carly Fiorina
is with us now Carly Fiorina joins us
now from Simi Valley did you win the
debate last night well i was very
satisfied with the debate i was very
satisfied you know when i went into that
debate almost half the audience had
never heard my name had never heard my
name and didn't know i was running for
president and so it was a really
important opportunity this was a huge
opportunity for me to continue to
introduce myself to the American people
I successfully introduced myself to
those who did not know me and
demonstrated once again that I am the
most qualified candidate on that stage
to win this job and to do this job and
what I'm finding honestly is if people
hear me if they see me if they
understand who I am and what I would do
they tend to be supportive and so I was
really pleased with last night mark
assuming you think as I do that carly
was the big winner of the debate last
night how do you think she's handling
her victory lap and what does she do
next anyone who's watched her grow as a
candidate over the last few months in
surprise she's been strong in the
debates but that was one of the stronger
debate performances in a nomination
debate any of us have ever seen she went
out on the show's showed the kind of
message discipline she has I think the
key thing for her is to raise money off
of this that's the most important thing
in the short term and I'll be curious to
see how much they're able to raise she
did a lot of debate prep together the
place that she was last night and she
did kill it I think throughout to me
obviously as you said raising money
super important but the other thing is
she has got to start getting ready for
what's coming her way which is a ton of
Oppo about her time at HP about her time
at lucent her business crews what killed
her when she ran in California against
Barbara Boxer it could really kill her
now too so she got to get ready for that
but she's totally you know and
intellectually invested in it she gets
the case to make her business record is
not as bad as a critic say it's not as
good as she says but this is not
somebody's going to be blindsided by any
facts I don't think to come up about
what she did that puts her in a
different position in some of these
candidates who come seemingly out of
nowhere but
that performance was strong and her
operation is just big enough and she's
sophisticated enough to take a fair
amount of advantage of it